bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce petit cours notre fil rouge de
l'été continue et aujourd'hui on sent
transition j'ai envie de dire on passe
du quart ou à l'évolution du cerveau
humain et de l'intelligence
un cours que je ne donne pas
habituellement
voilà je vais vous donner un petit peu
de contexte quand même c'est un cours
que je ne donne pas habituellement c'est
la première année que je vais le donner
d'habitude il est donné par une de mes
collègues qui s'appelle amélie baudet
docteur amélie beaudet qui est
aujourd'hui à cambridge et qui est une
spécialiste de l'évolution du cerveau
chez les hominidés
alors moi j'ai beau être à l'aise quand
même avec l'évolution des homininés je
n'en suis pas je n'en suis pas
spécialiste et je ne suis pas
spécialiste de l'évolution du cerveau
des homininés je suis pas les aux
neurologues comme amélie mais pas des
homininés voilà donc salut amélie mais
c'est moi qui tu remplaces voilà c'est
la cour que j'ai c'est que j'ai à tout
prix esquivé jusqu'à jusqu'à récemment
ben jusqu'à cette année en fait j'ai
essayé d'esquiver de données secours
parce que parce que je ne me sentais pas
hyper légitime a donné un cours pareil
mais bon ma foi c'est jamais qu'une
heure de ma vie et il faut juste que
j'évite de dire d'énormes bêtises quand
je le fais donc voila vous allez être
mais mes cochons d'inde vous allez être
mais cobayes pendant ce court et puis
bah vous ne devez vous me ferez savoir
dans les commentaires si vous avez
apprécié si vous avez appris des choses
j'ai pu constater que je prends une
approche qui est quand même très
différente de celle d'amélie mais en
même temps je prends une approche qui
est fait par un nombre à lyon
anthropologue donc c'est peut-être pour
ça aussi que je prends une approche
assez différentes
donc on va bien voir ben j'espère que si
amélie voient secours qu'elle me donnera
son qu'elle me donnera son avis voilà
donc aujourd'hui évolution du cerveau et
de l'intelligence chez les hominidés
donc déjà pour commencer on ne peut pas
parler intelligence sans parler cerveau
évidemment on va parler du cerveau à
tous pendant tout ce courant soyons
honnêtes
donc on ne peut pas parler intelligence
sans parler cerveau et on ne peut pas
parler cerveau dans le registre fossile
sans parler en doc as tu donc landau
caste ou moulage endocriniens en
français c'est le moulage de la cavité
crânienne
qui contient le cerveau donc ce moulage
de la boîte crânienne en réalité et la
première chose à savoir j'ai presque
envie de dire la seule chose importante
à savoir quand on parle de l'évolution
du cerveau dans l'espèce humaine
enfin dans les espèces humaines dans les
homininés et bien ça va être de savoir
que quand on part l'évolution du cerveau
en fait on ne parle pas du cerveau on
parle de l'évolution du moulage
endocriniens consignes ni mise peu ou
prou avec celle du cerveau et je vous ai
représenté sur cette image l'essence
même de la différence qu'il ya entre un
moulage endocriniens en bas et un
cerveau en haut un cerveau on voit tout
on voit les gyrus
on voit les succubes les seuls si donc
les gyrus ce sont les c'est le plat de
si vous représentez le cerveau comme un
plat de spaghettis l'élégie russe
l'égérie donc au pluriel
ce sont les spaghettis et les seuls si
ce sont les creux entre les spaghettis
voilà donc ici ce que vous avez là sur
ce cerveau bien ici par exemple vous
avez à succès qui sépare de jiri 1 au
dessus et en dessous de jeu pardon vous
avez un sursis qui sépare de jiri oui
c'est ça les pluriels les pluriels et
les singulier agit russe d'égérie
insultes us dé celle ci voilà donc on
peut voir l'égérie on peut voir les
soucis sur un cerveau on peut voir les
différentes parties du cerveau donc on
peut voir le si vous cherchez par
exemple le lobe frontal vous le
trouverez si vous cherchez le lobe
occipital vous le trouverez si vous
cherchez le cervelet alors là le
cervelet il est très très très très
visible ici par rapport au reste de lait
des hémisphères cérébraux sur ce cerveau
par contre si vous chercher ça sur un an
de crâne bas bonne chance voilà vous ne
les verrez pas et pareil vous pouvez
faire de l'histologie c'est à dire que
vous pouvez faire des coupes dans le
cerveau d'un d'un être humain et voir la
liste au logis à l'intérieur les
cellules voire la matière grise et la
matière blanche etc
si vous faites ça dans un an d'eau crâne
vous n'y verrez que la matière qui
constitue l'endocrâne voilà donc ça peut
être du sédiment ça peut être du
plastique ça peut être du plâtre mais en
tout cas vous n'y verrez rien niveau
histologique
et vous pouvez mesurer la taille et
quantifier la forme aussi éventuellement
de ce cerveau vous pouvez aussi faire ça
avec un endos crâne et c'est à peu près
la seule chose que vous pouvez faire
avec un endos crâne donc là je pense que
amélie m'en voudrait on dit quand je dis
qu'on verra pas de jiri ni de celle ci
mais la réalité c'est qu'on ne voit que
très très peu de 2j riz et de sucre 6
sur un an de crâne parce que l'endocrâne
n'est pas une copie fidèle de
l'extérieur du cerveau ça n'est que le
moulage de la boîte crânienne et le
problème c'est que chez les êtres
humains et celle et chez les grands
singes de manière générale vous avez une
épaisseur assez conséquente de ménage
par dessus le tissu cérébral
donc les ménages les ménages ça comprend
des vaisseaux sanguins
cela comprend des ça comprend la durham
à terre
ça comprend la pia mater donc pour ceux
qui ont fait de la ceux qui ont fait de
la neurobiologie là sont en train de
revivre des cauchemars absolument
abominable mais tout ça pour dire que
voilà il ya une épaisseur conséquente de
ménage de ce qu'on appelle les ménages
par dessus le cerveau qui sépare le
cerveau de la boîte crânienne et quand
on fait un moulage endocriniens ou quand
on étudie un moulage endocriniens
basques ont étudié en fait c'est la
surface de ses ménages
alors il ya des fois il ya certaines
espèces notamment les espèces de toute
petite taille où l'épaisseur de ménages
est tellement fine que ce qu'on voit
c'est vraiment la surface du cerveau et
on arrive à étudier ces giry et ses
succès mais chez les hominidés pas le
cas voilà donc le premier la première
chose à savoir c'est que quand on étudie
le cerveau chez les hominidés on va
généralement se contenter d'étudier la
taille du cerveau et c'est pour ça que
j'ai écrit size en gros sur cette diapos
on peut étudier aussi on a développé des
outils informatiques maintenant aussi
pour développer la forme du cerveau mais
ça c'est assez récent et je vais pas
trop en parler aujourd'hui on va surtout
parler taille de cerveau aujourd'hui
mais on peut aussi étudier
éventuellement la forme si vous avez les
outils informatiques pour
on est rond santé d'étudier la forme
avant aussi en faisant des mesures mais
les mesures ça reflète très très
mal la forme la forme de quelque chose
en plus c'est une forme très très simple
c'est un moulage endocrânienne vous
voyez c'est donc il ya pas beaucoup de
choses à étudier dans cette forme de
cerveau au final donc bref
donc la première chose à savoir c'est
que on est extrêmement limitée dans la
quantité d'informations qu'on va pouvoir
atteindre sur un cerveau voilà cette
diapositive en une phrase ce qu'on
étudie en réalité dans le registre
fossile ce n'est pas le cerveau et le
même moule à genthod crânien et le
moulage endocrânienne et le moulage
endocriniens fournit une quantité
d'informations très très faible comparé
à un véritable cerveau donc il ya même
certaines personnes qui vous diront ça
sert à rien d'étudier les moulages
endocriniens on n'y voit rien dessus et
ils n'auraient pas tort ils auraient
tort sur la partie où ça sert à rien
vous allez voir quand même qu'on peut
faire des choses avec un cerveau avec un
moulage endocriniens mais il ya des gens
qui préfèrent du coup faire de
l'anatomie comparée de cerveau de
primates modernes plutôt que d'étudier
les andes au crâne des espèces fossiles
et on ne leur en voudra pas parce que on
se prive en étudiant les ans au crâne de
beaucoup beaucoup d'informations mais
par contre quand on étudie que les
cerveaux des espèces modernes on se
prive de l'axé autant au registre
fossile donc il faut il faut utiliser un
juste équilibre des deux j'ai envie de
dire donc maintenant où est ce qu'on va
aller chercher ces moulages endocriniens
bas soit on a du bol
comme avec le ton child et la nature et
là le miracle de la fossilisation nous
nous prodigue ses bienfaits et nous
offre un moulage endocrânienne comme ça
naturel donc l'enfant de tongs et
probablement de l'exemple le plus
flagrant de moulage endocriniens voyez
on à la face donc on a los de la face
par contre l'os de la boîte crânienne a
été détruit mais par contre on a accès
du coup directement au moulage
endocriniens et on voit même les veines
du moulage endocriniens regarder le
moulage de cette veine ici est
magnifique
donc on a des détails anatomiques sur le
sur le moulage endocriniens sur des
moulages de crânes ya qui sont qui son
genre j'ai pas envie de dire réel mais
qui sont naturels voilà donc c'est le
sédiment qui naturellement a rempli la
boîte crânienne s'est durcie fossilisés
et du coup nous donne maintenant un
moulage endocrine
naturel la plupart du temps ce qu'on va
faire c'est quand même faire un moulage
endocriniens artificiel donc soit ici en
là on peut les faire en latex en en
plastique en plâtre en résine
enfin bref mais bon ça demande quand
même de vider les boîtes crâniennes
avant parce que avant de couler le la
résine ou le plâtre donc ça demande à
vider la boîte crânienne donc des fois
vous avez des petits coups de burin
meudon c'est pas c'est pas idéal
l'idéal aujourd'hui maintenant qu'on a
accès à cette technologie c'est
d'utiliser les rayons x
lorsqu'on appelle les sites is khan donc
c'est gilles ni plus ni moins qu elle
comme un scanner médical généralement
d'ailleurs c'est comme ça qu'ils sont
faits on utilise des scanners médicale
donc on utilise des rayons x pour
pouvoir accéder à l'intérieur des
fossiles sans avoir à les détruire
allait préparer ou a coulé du plâtre
dedans et c'est ce qui a été fait par
exemple avec messi se plaît ce que vous
voyez ici donc messi se plaît ce qui est
un australopithèque très connu donc
voilà différentes méthodes soient
naturels soit on utilise des andes au
crâne naturel soit d un ton crâne fait
artificiellement physiquement ou
numériquement et généralement ce qu'on
va faire avec ces moulages endocriniens
dont je vous ai parlé on peut essayer
d'aller trouver l'égérie et les seuls si
il ya quand même quelques giry et
quelques succès qui se voit là par
exemple vous avez un virus le gyrus qui
sépare le lobe temporal ici du lobe
frontal
ici on le voit relativement bien il est
là là on peut voir agir us ici qui
délimite le lobe frontal donc là c'est
pareil on peut voir certains virus mais
là ce que vous voyez là c'est le truc là
c'est pas des jus russe ce sont des
vaisseaux sanguins
enfin ce sont pas d'égérie ce sont des
vaisseaux sanguins d'ailleurs je parle
de gyrus pardon ces insultes q cela donc
vous avez le suc us qui sépare le lobe
temporal et le lobe frontal vous avez
ici le suc us qui se délimite le lobe
frontal est ici ce que vous voyez ce
n'est ni un virus ni insulte cus en
réalité c'est une vaine
enfin c'est un vaisseau sanguin donc il
faut faire très attention quand on
interprète ses 16 ans de crâne si on est
à la recherche de jiri de celle ci
des fois l'égérie et les subs si sûr
l'endocrâne d'ailleurs sont pas alignés
avec l'égérie et les sucs 6 sur le
cerveau lui-même en plus donc vous allez
croire que vous êtes en train de
regarder un os sur le sulky us qui
délimite le cortex préfrontal alors
qu'en fait le cortex préfrontal il est
le suc us qui correspond n'est pas là du
tout sur le vrai cerveau
par contre il est à cet endroit là sur
l'endocrâne donc bref on va pas trop en
parler aujourd'hui du coup parce que
comme vous voyez ces sujets à
interprétation
donc la chose principale qu'on va faire
avec ces moulages endocriniens va ça va
être de mesurer leur taille
on va mesurer leur taille et c'est
notamment ça qui va nous donner accès à
l'intelligence une des raisons pour
laquelle aussi je voulais pas j'étais
pas trop pressé de faire secours c'est
aussi parce que balleux la personne qui
dirige ce cours qui n'est pas moi veut
absolument qu'on fasse le pont avec
l'intelligence c'est pour ça que le
titre de cette course est intelligent
sans fin évolution du cerveau et de
l'intelligence chez les hominidés
or faire le pont avec l'intelligence
c'est quelque chose qui est
effectivement extrêmement débat table
extrêmement en discuter peut-on
réellement faire un pont entre taille de
cerveau et intelligence c'est déjà un
sujet en soi bon ben là je suis obligé
de le faire donc le meilleur moyen de
parler d'évolution du cerveau et
d'intelligence et de mesurer la taille
du cerveau et on va pas mesurer cette
taille n'importe comment
tout simplement parce que si vous
comparez juste la taille brut
vous allez rapidement vous rendre compte
que les gros animaux ont des gros
cerveau et je vous rappelle que
l'évolution humaine telle qu'on cela
représente habituellement on voit très
bien la transition entre des espèces de
petites tailles des espèces de grandes
tailles voyez le l'australopithèque qui
me le petit australopithèques qui marche
à quatre pattes et qui se redresse pour
devenir un fier homo sapiens bon ben là
ce redressement il s'accompagne aussi
d'une augmentation de la taille du corps
les australopithèques était beaucoup
plus petit que les homo sapiens donc on
s'attend à ce que les homo sapiens est
un plus gros cerveau vu qu'ils ont déjà
de base plus gros de tous trois enfants
plus grands et plus grand plus gros de
toute façon donc il va falloir corriger
pour ce biais qui est la taille du corps
et pour ça il va falloir donc avoir une
mesure qui prend en compte la taille du
corps
on a fait aussi par le passé des ratios
juste entre taille du cerveau die du
corps un simple ratio taille du cerveau
taille du corps le problème c'est que
bah si vous avez des extrêmes comme les
êtres humains par exemple qui ont un
extrêmement gros cerveau ou les baleines
qui ont un extrêmement gros corps bah en
fait cette ce ratio taille de cerveau
taille de corps du coup il va être
extrêmement biaisé ben il va être très
fortement biaisé par les extrêmes
voilà si vous avez un très très gros
corps comme une baleine
on va avoir l'impression que vous avez
un tout petit cerveau alors que les
baleines l ont pas un tout petit cerveau
sont très intelligentes les les baleines
sont des animaux très intelligente donc
le ratio taille de cerveau taille de
corps du coup ne refléterait pas cette
intelligence et du coup c'est un mauvais
ratio pour parler d'un thé révolution de
l'intelligence et pareil pour les êtres
humains pour les êtres humains on a
cerveau qui est extrêmement gros mais
qui du coup est tellement gros que en
fait ça saran le ratio complètement pas
sans valeur mais du coup le ratio va
être tellement élevé va être tellement
élevé chez les humains comparé aux
autres espèces qu'au final ça va pas
vous raconter grand chose ça va pas vous
raconter une histoire une histoire avec
beaucoup de détails vous allez juste
voir un fou un pic vers le haut comme ça
est bon ça vous ça vous dit pas grand
chose quoi vous voulez voir des jolies
transition quand vous quand vous vous
voulez étudier un sujet vous voulez voir
des jolies transition vous voulez pas
voir des anomalies
voilà les anomalies à vous n'êtes pas
donc à voir l'être humain qui finit en
anomalie surtout si c'est ça que vous
essayer d'étudier ça ne vous arrange pas
la vie donc on utilise un ratio qui
s'appelle le quotient danse et le
coefficient dans ses valises à sion en
français ou en cfa lisation cochons en
anglais et donc ce ratio ce n'est pas
juste la taille du cerveau sur la taille
du corps
c'est la taille du cerveau alors on peut
le mesurer en litres ou en centimètres
cubes je préfère les centimètres cubes
mais de toute façon ça revient
généralement ou même puisque le cerveau
c'est essentiellement de l'eau donc son
volume en centimètres cubes en revient à
son à son volume en litres
donc voilà et généralement son poids et
du coup son poids en grammes de fait
donc g centimètres cubes techniquement
millilitres si je me rappelle bien mais
bref taille de cerveau je digresse déjà
le coefficient dans ses valises à sion
s'est taillé de cerveau sur n'ont pas la
taille du corps mais sur la taille de
cerveau tel qu'on s'y attend dans un
animal de taille de taille de cerveau
moyenne est de 7 et 2 et de poids
équivalent
c'est ce qu'il ya d'écrit là sur 7 sur 7
diapos juste ici donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça c'est qu'on va prendre la
taille de cerveau mesures et celles qui
nous intéressent donc on a notre moulage
endocrânienne mesure la taille de ce
cerveau soit si on a fait un si on a des
données digitales dont on va pouvoir
mesurer directement sur le logiciel
si on a un cerveau qui est qui est
physique on va dire un cerveau qui est
un moulage endocriniens physique en
plâtre par exemple on va le plonger dans
l'eau et on va voir quelle quantité
d'eau ils déplacent par poussée
d'archimède tout simple et on va comme
ça réussir à savoir quel volume il fait
donc on obtient ce volume de cerveau est
en fait ce volume de cerveau on va le
comparer au volume de cerveau moyen
d'une espèce de même poids donc de
taille corporelle équivalente
et si ce volume de cerveau est
supérieure à la volume de cerveau moyen
d'une espèce de taille corporelle
équivalente alors ça veut dire que notre
espèce là elle a un plus gros cerveau
que ce qui est attendu
d'après la taille de son corps et si on
a un volume de cerveau qui est plus
petit plus petit que le volume du
cerveau d'une espèce le volume du
cerveau moyen d'une espèce de même masse
corporelle et bien ça veut dire que le
cerveau est plus petit que ce à quoi on
s'attend donc ça veut dire quotient dans
ses valises à sion supérieur à 1
quand la taille de cerveau pardon cause
que cautionne encéphale isation ici à
droite supérieur à 1 quand le cerveau
est plus gros que la valeur attendue
étant donné le poids du corps ou
quotient dans ses valises à sion
inférieure à 1
si si le poids du cerveau est inférieure
à ce à quoi on s'attend étant donné le
poids du corps voilà donc et ça revient
à dire gros cerveau petit cerveau voilà
c'est donc à droite gros cerveau
coefficient dans ses valises à sion
supérieur à 1 à gauche petit cerveau
coefficient de l'encéphale isation
inférieur 1 et cette façon de calculer
le quotient dans ses valises à sion elle
a un corollaire intéressant en terme
d'intelligence c'est qu'en fait vous
avez donc le poids du cerveau d'un
animal moyens enfin enfin vous avez le
poids du cerveau moyen d'un animal de
même poids dans votre calcul et cette
taille de cerveau d'un animal de même
poids cette taille de cerveau moyenne
d'un animal de même poids en fait c'est
la taille du cerveau qu'il faut pour
coordonner les mouvements d'un animal
qui a le même corps en fait ça
correspond en fait à votre masse mortes
entre guillemets de cerveau j'ai envie
de dire c'est la masse de cerveau qu'il
vous faut pour coordonner ce corps donc
c'est la masse de cerveau qu'il vous
faut pour faire des choses qui sont pas
spécialement intelligente qui demandent
pas l'intelligence donc par conséquent
tout tout masse de cerveau qui se
rajoute à cette masse de cerveau moyenne
peut-être interprété en matière
d'intelligence
donc c'est ce qu'il ya d'écrit ici dans
cette seconde boîte donc ce qui est donc
quand vous avez un quotient dans ses
valises à sion supérieur à 1 ça veut
dire que vous avez un cerveau qui est
plus gros que ce à quoi on s'attend pour
un animal de masse corporelle
équivalente
ça veut dire que vous avez du cerveau en
plus par rapport à ce dont vous avez
réellement besoin
tout simplement ça veut dire que vous
avez du cerveau en plus par rapport à ce
dont vous avez besoin est ça jerry sonne
en 1973 nous dit que c'est de
l'intelligence
enfin du moins c'est comme ça qu'on veut
l'interpréter en tout cas c'est comme ça
que lui l'a interprété et les gens l'ont
plutôt suivi voilà les gens sont plutôt
d'accord avec ça et de l inverse si vous
avez un poids de cerveau inférieurs à
ceux
à ce à quoi on s'attend eba étant donné
la masse de votre corps bâle a du coup
vous vous êtes plutôt interprétée comme
étant un animal moins intelligents que
ce que vous êtes censés être voilà étant
donné le poids de votre corps donc voilà
donc tout
donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs le principe de masse propre
c'est à dire que vous avez votre masse
propre coefficient dans ses valises à
sion égal à 1
le concorde coefficient dans ses valises
à sion égal à 1 vous avez juste ce qu'il
faut de cerveau pour juste ce qu'il faut
de corps si vous êtes au dessus de ça
vous avez de l'intelligence en plus si
vous êtes en dessous de ça vous avez de
l'intelligence en moins c'est ce que
nous dit jay harrison en 1973 dans son
livre fondateur de la paléo neurologie
et qui a été évidemment quand même
accepté mais discuté il ya quand même
des limitations à ça je vais revenir à
la diapo là mais évidemment il ya des
limitations assez évidente à ça les
limitations évidente étant déjà le
nombre de neurones donc pour comparer
par exemple un cerveau humain qui fait
en moyenne un kilo et demi voire un peu
moins que ça a beaucoup plus de neurones
cas que le cerveau d'un éléphant
d'afrique qui lui fait entre 2 et 5 kg
voyez il ya 16 milliards de neurones
chez un humain il y en a seulement 5
milliards 6 milliards chez chez
l'éléphant alors que l'éléphant a un
cerveau beaucoup plus gros donc
donc il ya le nombre de neurones et
évidemment il ya les connexions donc là
vous avez une représentation très
stylisé du connecte home qui est le réel
la somme des connexions de de vos
neurones à l'intérieur de votre cerveau
évidemment plus vous avez de connexion
et plus votre cerveau à carburer voilà
donc il ya évidemment il ya des
limitations évidente et là je vous parle
que des limitations évidente y en a
plein d'autres un des limitations
évidente mais de toute façon comme on
n'a que des moulages endocriniens et ça
et ça ça va répondre à à peu près toutes
les questions que je vais avoir en
commentaire et ça répond à toutes les
questions que j'ai dans les cours de
toute façon à chaque fois que je me mets
à parler de cerveau c'est que de toute
façon on n'a pas le choix on n'a que les
moulages endocriniens on n'a pas accès
au nombre de neurones on n'a pas accès
aux
eq tome on a accès à rien d'autre que le
moulage endocrânienne donc ça il faut
vous l'enfoncer dans la tête
donc on peut rien faire d'autre que des
hypothèses raisonnables basées sur la
taille du cerveau c'est tout donc tout
ce que je vais vous dire aujourd'hui ce
sont des hypothèses raisonnables basées
sur la taille du moulage endocriniens
d'ailleurs même pas du cerveau g10
cerveau mais je devrais dire moulage
endocriniens donc ce sont des hypothèses
raisonnables basées sur la taille du
moulage endocriniens dont on déduit que
la taille du cerveau devait être plus ou
moins équivalente
bien que je vous rappelle il ya une
épaisseur de ménage non négligeable dans
cette histoire il ya quand même une
épaisseur de ménage non négligeable et
les ménages c'est pas du tissu qui
réfléchit c'est pas de la matière grise
ou de la matière blanche ou quoi que ce
soit c'est pas c'est pas des neurones
les ménages
c'est juste du tissu autour du cerveau
qui le protège et l'alimentent
voilà donc donc tout ceci étant dit tout
ceci étant bien dit bien expliquer bien
rappelé voilà je tiens à dire il faut se
rendre compte que on n'a que ça on n'a
que ça on n'a que les moulages
endocriniens donc toutes les histoires
qu'on peut vous raconter sur l'évolution
du cerveau humain ne peuvent être basés
que là dessus
voilà bref et donc quand on regarde les
moulages endocriniens et qu'on calcule
leur quotient dans ses valises à sion et
bien on constate une augmentation du
quotient dans ses valises à sion depuis
les premiers hominidés donc les
australopithèques par exemple toumaï à
moins 7 millions d'années aura une
taille de cerveau équivalente à
australopithecus le poids du corps est à
peu près le même
le poids du cerveau est à peu près le
même donc on est sur des cerveaux de 400
centimètres cubes chez toumaï
australopithèque us donc ici on est sur
un coefficient dans ses valises à sion
de l'ordre de 3 donc on est quand même
sur trois fois la taille du cerveau à
laquelle on s'attend dans un animal de
même taille corporelle
en tout cas pour un mammifère
j'entendais quand je dis animaux là
évidemment ce sont des cautions dans ses
valises à sion ajusté sur les mammifères
donc on est trois fois la taille du
cerveau
attendu chez un mammifère voilà pour
vous donner un exemple un animal qui a
une taille de cerveau est exactement la
même que celle attendue pour le poids de
son corps
le cheval les éléphants par exemple ils
ont une taille de cerveau qui est
attendu étant donné la taille de leur
corps voilà à peu près évidemment il ya
des variations tout n'est pas absolu
c'est pas absolument à le dire mais
voilà donc on est sur des animaux qui
ont quand même une certaine intelligence
notamment une intelligence sociale ce
sont des animaux qui sont sociaux qui
sont pas justes grégaire je dire ils
sont sociaux de manière générale sont
des interactions entre eux entre groupe
2 entre les individus ils ont une
certaine chez les éléphants on a même
une certaine intelligence
j'avais envie de dire you man like mais
voilà une certaine intelligence qu'on
peut se dans laquelle on peut
s'identifier à savoir qu'ils arrivent à
reconnaître les ossements de leurs
défunts ils les rassemblent donc ça
ressemble quand même à une certaine
conscience de la mort les éléphants sont
capables d'émettre des des signes de
douleur mentale
donc la dépression pour dire les choses
un cheval aussi peu montré des signes de
dépression
bref vous avez des animaux qui sont
quand même qu'on considère comme
intelligent et qu'on n'a pas de mal à
entrer au pommeau refusé si vous voulez
on n'a pas de mal à rentrer pour
morphine est un éléphant ou un cheval ya
même des gens qui entrent aux pommes en
fils à mort leurs chevaux aller visiter
le aller visiter le château de chantilly
si vous ne me croyez pas voilà si vous
connaissez le palais de chantilly vous
saurez que l'on peut anthropomorphes
usées à mort un cheval c'est le cas le
plus extrême que je connais
d'anthropomorphisme à sion en général
donc bref ce sont des animaux qu'on n'a
pas de mal à rentrer au pommeau refusé
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas de mal à
identifier chez eux des comportements
qui sont très humains voire même à les
humaniser beaucoup plus qu'ils ne le
sont réellement
prenez un crocodile par exemple là on
est sur du quotient dans ses valises à
sion très très très très bas très très
très bas on n'ose même pas appliquée
d'ailleurs les quotients dans ses
valises à sion d'un malien sur les
reptiles tellement ils sont bas chez les
reptiles donc lassé de ces de l'animal
qu'on arrive pas on trouve au murphy's
et de manière générale on a beaucoup de
mal à se reconnaître dans le
comportement d'un serpent ou d'un
crocodile
voilà et je tiens à rappeler mais c'est
quelque chose qu'on avait déjà dit dans
une vidéo précédente je tiens à rappeler
que notre seule mesure de l'intelligence
c'est l'intelligence humaine
donc c'est pas la peine de me dire c'est
pas la peine de m'expliquer des choses
que je sais déjà sur bari mais on sait
pas s'ils sont intelligentes
on parle de toute façon d'intelligence
qu'un être humain est capable de
reconnaître est un être humain ne peut
reconnaître qu'une intelligence qui lui
ressemble
c'est un billet on peut pas y échapper
c'est tout c'est pareil ça aussi il va
falloir il va falloir bien comme il faut
s'asseoir sur ceux sur cet axiome parce
que ce niveau là c'est axiomatique nous
sommes des êtres humains nous ne pouvons
identifier qu'une intelligence humaine
ou qui ressemble à celle de l'être
humain donc par exemple l exemple que
j'utilise toujours c'est les dauphins si
si nous en tant qu'êtres humains nous
étions incapables de détecter les
ultrasons que font les dauphins dont
imaginez un monde où on ne connaît pas
les ultras sion je veux dire c'est de la
technologie pour nous les ultrasons il a
existé l'histoire humaine a été plus
longue sans notre connaissance des
ultrasons qu'avec le bref donc imaginer
qu'on ai aucune idée que les du fait que
les dauphins utilise un sauna bain on ne
saurait pas qu'ils communiquent entre
eux on n'aurait aucune idée de ses et
pourtant c'est un trait d'intelligence
de savoir communiquer nous considérons
cela comme un trend intelligence mais si
on n'était pas capable de le voir de
l'entendre en l'occurrence ce n'était
pas capable de le savoir on ne saurait
pas que les dauphins sont intelligents
de ce point de vue là donc il faut
jamais perdre de vue le fait qu' on est
extrêmement dépendants de nos
perceptions voilà en plus du fait qu'on
ne peut reconnaître qu'une intelligence
qui ressemble à la nôtre on est en plus
extrêmement dépendants de nos
perceptions
j'en étais donc non mais dès qu'on parle
d'intelligence de toute façon ça
s'enflamme dans les commentaires donc je
préfère répondre dès maintenant aux
grandes questions qui vont se poser
puisque je les connais davance
bref donc australopithecus a déjà un
cerveau comme je disais qui est trois
fois la taille attendu étant donné le
poids de son corps ensuite on monte
alors pas rentrer up est globalement
équivalent
on monte ensuite chez les premiers
représentants du genre homo abelli
habilis et les premiers homo erectus qui
ont un cerveau globalement un peu plus
gros que ceux des australopithèques
alors c'est on est d'accord que c'est
pas non plus ça peut être pas trois
pattes à un canard mais il ya une
certaine variabilité on en parlera de la
variabilité un petit peu plus tard mais
en gros le cerveau chez les premiers
membres du genre homo donc à savoir homo
habilis par exemple il est deux fois en
moyenne deux fois plus gros que celui
des australopithèques donc on a on va
dire un premier bond dans la taille du
cerveau et donc on arrive à un quotient
dans ses valises à sion qui va aller
flirter entre 4 et 5 et ensuite on a un
nouveau bond dans la taille du cerveau
chez les homos tardif donc née
typiquement les néandertal et d'albert
gagnent 6 et les sapiens ou là le
cerveau va atteindre facilement
au-dessus de 1000 cm cube donc encore
une multiplication par 2 de la taille du
cerveau en moyenne est donc là on
atteint un quotient dans ses valises à
sion qui va être proche de celui des
humains modernes donc entre 6 et 8
généralement on admet que cette voie là
après ça dépend du quotient dans ses
valises à sion que vous utilisez je vous
ai épargné la formule du co2 du quotient
dans ses valises à sion a parce que
c'est une ouvreuse formule mathématique
et en plus il n'en existe pas cas de
quotient dans ses valises à sion c'est à
dire que vous pouvez réduire par exemple
votre caution d'un sefa lisation seul
primate où vous pouvez l'adapter aux
mammifères ou vous pouvez exclure
certaines espèces que vous considérez
comme étant pas très représentatif
typiquement l'être humain typiquement
l'être humain ce n'est pas une espèce
très représentatif vous voulez un
quotient dans ses valises à sion où la
plupart de vos espèces seront autour de
donc évidemment plus vous avez de doubt
liars donc d'exception à la règle plus
moi la règle est bien défini donc bref
donc c'est pour ça que je vous épargne
aussi la formule du quotient
d'encéphalite à sion c'est parce qu'il
ya plusieurs quotient dans ses valises à
sion mais en général la plupart des
cautions dans ses valises à sion
s'accorde à dire que homo sapiens
inconscience dans ses valises à sion
autour de 7
voilà en tout cas au dessus de 5 et donc
le voilà vous avez donc ces trois étapes
dans l'évolution
vous avez le petit cerveau avec un
quotient dans ses valises à sion entre 3
et 4 le cerveau de taille moyenne chez
les premiers représentants du genre homo
entre 4 et 5
caution dans ses valises à sion et après
au dessus de 6 chez les espèces tardif
du genre au monde
donc c'est ce que j'appelle la vue
classique de l'évolution du cerveau
humain à savoir une vision linéaire de
l'évolution du cerveau humain donc une
évolution du cerveau qui commence avec
un petit cerveau donc un cerveau
d'australopithèques à autour de 400 500
centimètres cubes taille équivalente à
peu près à celle du cerveau d'âge
imposée suivi à l'origine du genre homo
donc chez les premiers représentants du
genre homo comme aux beaux habits lise
d'une multiplication par deux du volume
en doc rania qui passe à 800 milles
centimètres cubes donc les premiers
représentants du genre homo ont un
cerveau qui est déjà deux fois plus gros
que ceux de leurs ancêtres
australopithèques sin donc les
australopithèques et et autres et
ensuite vous avez les représentants
tardif du genre homo donc typiquement
ici vous avez néandertal vous avez homo
sapiens vous avez and albert guen 6
homologué pour citer le nouveau en
dragon qui vient d'être publié tout ça
ce sont des homos qui ont un cerveau
très très gros deux fois plus gros que
celui des premiers homo autour de 1200 à
1600 centimètres cube voit la vision
linéaire de l'évolution du cerveau
simplifiée classique classique est
simple j'ai envie de dire évidemment si
je vous la présente de cette façon c'est
qu'il va y avoir des petites
il va y avoir des nuances à ajouter à
tout ça mais ça je vous en parlerai
après déjà parlons de l'évolution
justement de l'intelligence donc déjà
niveau intelligence on peut se dire
l'intelligence a augmenté avec la taille
de cerveau puisque si on suit le
principe de la masse propres on avait un
quotient dans ses valises à sion qui
était de 3 qui est passé à 5 puis qui
est passé à 6 voire à 7
donc on a une augmentation de
l'intelligence augmentation qui est qui
et du coup uniquement quantifiables en
quotient dans ses valises à sion je veux
dire je ne peux pas vous dire à quel
point australopithèques était moins
intelligents que qu'un premier cas
premiers représentants du genre homo et
je ne peux pas vous dire à quel point
homo habilis était moins intelligents
que les premiers représentants d'homo
sapiens c'est juste quantifier en termes
de caution dans ses valises à sion voilà
à partir du quotient dans ses valises à
sion on s'attend à ce que il y ait eu de
plus en plus de masse de cerveau qui
n'était pas juste dédié à la
coordination du corps voilà c'est ça
c'est juste ça que ça vous dit allô
caution dans ses valises à sion ça ne
dit rien d'autre que ça il ya plus en
plus de masse de cerveau qu'on ne peut
pas expliquer simplement par la
coordination motrice
voilà et donc on va regarder l'évolution
des techniques le fait parce que
l'évolution des techniques
là par contre ça va vous donner une
certaine idée de l'évolution de
l'intellect des gens qui ont produit ces
techniques est évidemment la première
chose à laquelle on pense c'est
évidemment les outils dont quand on
regarde l'évolution des outils qu'est ce
qu'on voit eh bien on constate que les
premiers outils apparaissent il y à 3,3
millions millions d'années dont 3,3
millions d'années à l'époque c'était les
australopithèques signer dans l'est de
l'afrique on a ce qu'on appelle le lot
mais croyant est seul aux mecquois yaba
ce sont des gros cailloux qu'on a cassé
voilà ce sont des gros cailloux cassé si
vous n'êtes pas archéologue et si vous
les trouvez pas en contexte
archéologique
c'est juste des cailloux cassé mais par
contre quand vous les trouvez en
contexte archéologique et quand vous
avez l'oeil entraîné pour ça vous y
voyez des outils très très très
rudimentaire beaucoup plus rudimentaires
de que ce qu'on appelle l' auld au moyen
donc l'hôte de royat qui apparaît il ya
2,6 millions d'années qui est
généralement associée à l'origine du
genre homo 2,6 millions d'années
origines du genre homo homo habilis
notamment qui est en partie définit
l'origine du genre homo est en partie
définit par le fait qu'il est
généralement associé avec des outils en
fait si vous vous rappelez les
discussions qu'on a eues sur la
définition du genre au monde
donc ces outils sont extrêmement
importants ces outils hall du baiia sont
extrêmement importants pour la
définition du genre dont ils sont
associés les uns aux autres
et donc c'est le top du voyage passé
comme du lot mais khwaja mais en à peine
plus raffiné quoi en gros c'est ça reste
des outils taillés voilà c'est dit
chopper s'est pas encore du bifaces le
bis face il apparaît avec la schl est à
un cheveu inquiets à 1,8 million
d'années en gros associé à homo erectus
et 7h les uns qu'on associe homo erectus
là c'est ce qu'on commence à vraiment
appeler des bifaces voilà donc là on a
une belle symétrie qui apparaît avec 7 h
les uns
ensuite on à la domestication du feu
alors la domine je parle bien de
domestication du feu le feu devient
contrôler parce que si on parle de feux
incontrôlés alors les oiseaux aussi
contre sont capables de faire du feu
alors je vous rappelle que les rapaces
ne sont pas content certaines espèces de
rapaces ne sont pas contre aller
ramasser des petites brindilles en feu
pour aller les transporter le feu
ailleurs comme sale incendie va faire
sortir leurs proies de leur terrier
voyez donc on parle bien avec l'être
humain d'une d'une utilisation contrôlée
du feu parce que sinon d'utilisation
juste du feu on l'a depuis 2,5 millions
d'années
les premières les premières utilisations
du feu par les êtres humains associés
avec des êtres humains c'est la grotte
de swarte craintes qui aida tête 2 5
millions d'années donc là on parle d'une
utilisation contrôlée avec un foyer et
tout et ça c'est 600 mille ans donc 600
milles en homo sapiens est pas encore là
on est à 600 mille ans et l'origine des
dahlberg m6 où c'est l'origine de
néandertal aussi à 600 millions ce
serait plus ou moins l'ancêtre en commun
entre néandertal et l'homo sapiens quoi
600 mille ans
et puis après vous avez le middle stone
age qui commence l'âge de la pierre la
peur
l'âge de la pierre moyens qui commence
il ya trois cent mille ans avec
l'origine d'homo sapiens et puis après
avec homo sapiens vous avez une
accélération technologique que je ne
peut pas résumer en une diapo mais vous
connaissez enfin je veux dire on est
passé de l'âge de pierre à l'âge de
l'informatique en un clin d'oeil j'ai
envie de dire autant
l'échelle des temps géologiques donc
voilà ça c'est l'évolution des
techniques donc pareil une évolution des
techniques qui apparaît linéaire et qui
semble devenir de plus en plus complexes
au fur et à mesure que le cerveau
s'agrandit donc ça c'est l'image que
j'ai envie de dire classique de
l'évolution du cerveau par rapport à
l'évolution de la des techniques à ça on
va associer de nouveaux comportements et
notamment l'un des comportements les
plus importants pour nous ce sont les
comportements symbolique des
comportements symbolique de type
enterrement des morts donc jusqu'à
récemment la tombe la plus ancienne
connue était était celle d'anne et
envers talent qui datent de cent mille
ans donc c'est celle que vous voyez sur
la droite ce sont c'est une véritable
tombe je veux dire le corps a été
volontairement placé d'une certaine
façon pour pour que vraiment le corps
soit préservée et est enterré etc et on
a même des mêmes des traces
archéologiques de pollen qui montre que
des fleurs ou qui suggère du moins que
des fleurs aurait pu être déposée donc
on a de nombreuses tombes de néandertal
qui peuvent remonter jusqu'à au moins
cent mille ans mais très récemment on a
découvert en afrique de l'est une
possible tombe d'homo sapiens qui date
de trois cent mille ans donc on a des
tombes d'homo sapiens qui pourrait être
plus qui pourrait être presque aussi
vieille que homo sapiens lui-même dans
en afrique après les vrais les vrais
tombe reconnu les vraies premières
tombes connues d'homo sapiens qui sont
vraiment reconnus comme des tombes
c'est ce sont celles de
qu'on a retrouvé en israël de skull & 2
4z je crois hélas elles ont 90 millions
en la plus vieille des deux je sais plus
laquelle est la plus vieille des deux
mais en gros elles ont 90 millions et
celle là elles sont reconnues les plus
vieilles tombes en afrique de l'est
qu'on a retrouvée on sait qu'on n'est
pas quand même on n'est pas sûr sûr que
ce soit des tombes
on n'est même pas sûr sûr que ce soit
homo sapiens d'ailleurs pour dire les
choses
pour dire les choses comme elles sont
c'est reconnaître une tombe c'est
extrêmement difficile contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire c'est très
difficile de faire la différence entre
un corps qui a été juste mort comme ça
et un corps qui a été disposé
volontairement comme ça c'est très très
très difficile donc il ya énormément de
débat évidemment mais bon voilà en gros
on est plutôt d'accord pour dire que
homo sapiens et homo dernier néandertal
n 6 ont développé le concept de tombe en
même temps voilà donc commencé à mettre
de côté les corps de leurs congénères
d'une façon qui n'était pas complètement
aléatoire et dont il soulignait le fait
que d'une certaine conscience de la mort
voilà parce que nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est ça en finale c'est pas
de savoir s'il faisait des tombes ou pas
assez c'est de connaître le mécanisme
cognitif qui a derrière aix mécanismes
cognitifs
ce mec à louis ce mécanisme collectif
c'est la conscience de soi et de la mort
et de sa propre mortalité du coup et
puis il ya eu au monal et 10 en 2015 qui
est venu un peu fou de son bordel parce
que alors vous aussi vous vous y
connaissez réellement beaucoup vous
savez qu'à 1,8 2 millions d'années en
espagne on à la cimade et los masos où
on a possiblement décor dont nos
ancêtres les homo antecessor se serait
débarrassé mais pas vraiment de façon
religieuse mais en tout cas il y aurait
eu volonté de se débarrasser des corps
dans un genre de fosses communes mais
oui mais le problème c'est qu'ils y
balance est aussi leurs restes
alimentaires et puis on a aussi des
traces de cannibalisme qui sont aussi
vieilles que ça et le cannibalisme comme
vous le savez peut-être rituel est pas
forcément alimentaire il peut être
rituel aussi donc peut-être qu'on a des
traces
de pensée symbolique jusqu'à deux
millions d'années en gros mais elles
sont toutes extrêmement débattue parce
que bas parce que à la cimade et los
masos on n'a pas que des humains on a de
tout et on a des restes alimentaires
notamment donc c'est difficile de dire
si si les ossements dumas avait une
quelconque signification différente de
celle des ossements d'animaux qu'ils
avaient balancé dans le même trou et
c'est difficile de dire si les traces de
découpe les traces de cannibalisme des
d'autres populations contemporaines ou
plus récentes du cou avait une
signification une signification spéciale
on sait qu'il ya du cannibalisme chez
néandertal est ce que ça avait une
signification particulière ça par contre
c'est une grande question mais bref en
tout cas en tout cas on a ça et puis on
a en 2015 au monal et dick est venu
[ __ ] sa merde donc au monal eddy un
être humain à tout petit cerveau à
conscient d'un quotient dans ses valises
à sion équivalent à celui des tout
premiers homo des tout premiers
représentants du genre homo
donc retour de 3,4 de caution dans ses
valises à sion au monal et 10 à quelque
part dans une grotte en afrique du sud
balancer des corps et créer un dépôt
mono spécifique en fait donc c'est ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui je veux dire un
dépôt mono spécifique on a une grotte
avec une chambre et dans cette chambre
on ne retrouve que aumône aller dit il
n'ya rien d'autre
il n'y a pas d'autres animaux donc c'est
pas un piège c'est pas un piège naturel
ces décors qui ont été balancés là est
la grande question c'est déjà ça ça
souligne du coup qu'il ya eu une volonté
de balancer les corps l'a déjà d'une et
deux de la deuxième grande question
c'est est-ce que ce est ce que cette
attention était religieuse ou pas enfin
rituels ou pas vous avez deux heures
parce que là c'est donc en tout cas
aumône alesi ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il a
dans cette chambre qui s'appelle la
chambre d'inhaler dit il y a quinze
corps quinze corps qui tous
appartiennent à au monal est dit et il
n'y a rien d'autre pas de restes
alimentaires même pas de plantes
il ya quelques
carbo qui sont perdus là mais on pense
pas que c'est au monal a dit kylie kylie
les amis bref voilà donc on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas juste expliquer sa part
ces quelques mots naledi qui se sont
retrouvés perdu là parce que 6e
c'était juste perdu la balle y aurait
d'autres animaux qui se serait perdu au
même endroit et si c'était à 6 et un
garde-manger qui s'était qui s'était
retrouvé perdu il y aurait le reste de
la bouffe et puis si ces homos naledi
avait vécu là bas on aurait vu des
traces de feu on aurait vu des traces
d'activité il n'y a pas de ça non plus
donc pour autant qu'on sache il ya
quinze corps et ses corps était déjà
mort quand ils sont arrivés là voilà et
ça à 250 mille ans donc c'est plus vieux
que ce qu'on a deux certifiés pour homo
sapiens et homo neanderthalensis et ça
appartient à une espèce domo qui a un
tout petit cerveau comparé à homo
sapiens et homo neandertalensis un
cerveau qui est de l'ordre de 600
centimètres cubes quoi donc c'est la
moitié d'un homo néandertal et c'est un
tiers d'un homo sapiens quoi donc qu
est-ce qu comment on interprète ça en
terme d'intelligence
on nage on nage en pleine confusion on
nage en pleine confusion et ce serait
mentir de dire qu'on a la réponse
aujourd'hui c'est très clairement comme
ça qu'il faut le dire nos middle stone
age donc au middle stone age on parle d'
homo sapiens 1 c'est tout ce que je vais
vous dire la propos du midwest honnête
ça ne s'applique que à homo sapiens donc
au middle stone age
on va avoir au niveau de l'intelligence
ce qu'on appelle une explosion de la
modernité culturelle et une explosion de
la diversité culturelle alors qu'est ce
qu'on appelle la modernité culturelle
c'est qu'on va commencer à voir dans le
registre archéologiques des
comportements qu'on arrive encore une
fois identifié comme étant le reflet
d'une intelligence très proches des
humains modernes et puis il faut savoir
que au paléolithique
il ya trois cent mille ans donc au début
du midol stone age au début du
paléolithique moyen on a déjà homo
sapiens singles les plus anciens homo
sapiens ont trois cent mille ans donc on
n'a pas trop de mal à s'imaginer que
tout ça ça a été fait par homo sapiens
mais ce sont des homo sapiens de
morphologie archaïque donc
on bat grosse bourre les suces orbitaire
est pas encore de menton bien développé
jebali route par exemple le crâne de
djebel les routes par exemple
donc au début du paléolithique on a des
homo sapiens archaïque et on a encore
des espèces humaines qui traîne comme
par exemple mona lee dit donc on n'est
pas complètement sûr que ce que ce dont
je vais vous parler là appartiennent à
100% sapiens mais on a de bonnes raisons
de croire quand même que ça appartient
homo sapiens et notamment ce sont des
comportements qui sont très proches de
ceux des homo sapiens chasseurs
cueilleurs moderne donc qu'est-ce qu'on
a déjà dans en termes de modernité
culturelle on à l'utilisation de
peinture les autres donc ici ce que vous
voyez c'est un coquillage déballonne à
l'intérieur duquel il y avait de locre
et que cette offre sept baleines étaient
utilisés comme réservoir à eau cre pour
peindre soit peindre les murs mais on
n'a pas de retrouver de peintures
murales contemporaine soit pour peindre
le corps de ses congénères il faut
savoir que la peinture de corps des
congénères ça peut être un geste
culturel
ça peut aussi être un simple geste
fonctionnel
parce que l'offre ça protège des
moustiques et autres parasites de la
peau donc donc probablement un signe de
modernité culturelle oui mais pas
complètement le vrai gros signe de
modernité culturelle le plus ancien et
le plus convaincant qu'on est
c'est ce petit bout d'os cre la petit
bout d'os cre là qui a été gravé avec
des motifs géométriques et c'est la
gravure de ses motifs géométriques qui
nous indique une modernité culturelle et
du coup une modernité cognitif pourquoi
parce que ça ne sert à rien eh oui
l'être humain exprime sa culture à
travers des gestes qui ne servent à rien
des de la production non fonctionnels
donc la faire des petites gravure
géométriques sur ce bloc re c'est
peut-être un détail pour vous mais ça ne
sert à rien ça ne sert à rien ça ne
rendra pas l'offre plus facile à
utiliser ça ne ça ne sert à rien c'est
de l'art du couple c'est de l'art et
l'art c'est de la modernité culturelle
voilà donc et ça c'est à 80 mille ans
donc là les petites les petites
coquilles à que je vous ai montré là ça
sent milan et ce serait donc les plus
vieilles preuve de modernité
culturelle qu'on est à cent mille ans
donc là on est définitivement sur des
homo sapiens moderne quoi anatomiquement
modernes la 80 mille ans c'est pareil on
est sur du mono sapiens anatomiquement
modernes faut savoir que l'ancêtre en
commun de toutes les populations d'homo
sapiens qui vivent aujourd'hui a
supposément vécu il ya 120 mille ans
donc là on est sûr sur de l'homo sapiens
qui nous ressembler trait pour trait on
a ses petites ces petites perles ici
fait en coquillages donc vous voyez le
petit trou le petit trou qui a été usée
par une corde donc on est sûr que ça a
servi à faire un collier donc ça c'est
pareil ça à 80 mille ans on a des
morceaux de coquille d'oeufs d'autruche
de duff d'autruche des morceaux de
coquille d'un oeuf d'autruche qui était
utilisé comme gourde qui ont aussi 100
120 mille ans donc qui montre aussi une
certaine intelligence mais ça c'est
pareil c'est fonctionnel donc ce n'est
pas de l'art donc vraiment les preuves
les plus solides qu'on a de modernité
culturelle artistique donc une pensée
abstraite et bien ce sens et ce morceau
doc et ce collier qui en quatre-vingt
mille ans et qui viennent d'afrique du
sud tous les deux d'une grotte qui
s'appelle blond bosse dans l'extrême sud
de l'afrique du sud
est-ce qu'on voit aussi apparaître au
middle stone age et qui n'est pas aussi
récents que ça ça va être une diversité
au niveau de la taille des outils c'est
à dire que partout en afrique en fait on
va voir apparaître des poches culturel
en fait des différentes manières de
taille et les outils en fonction des
zones géographiques
et ça ça veut dire bah ça c'est le début
justement de la diversité culturelle et
ça s'est aussi associée au middle stone
age
on commence à voir déjà les traces de
population qui se fragmente et qui
culturellement se mettent à évoluer dans
leur coin et c'est aussi pour ça peut
être que les comportements qu'on voit à
blon beauce n'ont pas encore été
retrouvées ailleurs câblo moss c'est
parce que justement cette modernité
culturelle serait pas forcément répandu
partout
c'est aussi dans ces eaux là qu'on va
commencer à voir les premières
collections de fossiles d'ailleurs à
titre à titre purement paléontologique
les premières traces de fossile donc
qu'ils sont vieux de plusieurs millions
d'années mais qui ont été
intentionnellement collectés pour être
ramenées dans des sites qui sont ensuite
devenus des sites archéologiques et bien
ça date un peu près du middle stone age
aussi ça vient d'afrique aussi et ça
s'est développé aussi en parallèle en
europe avec néandertal donc il ya aussi
et faut pas le perdre de vue il ya aussi
en parallèle néandertal qui développe sa
propre modernité culturelle à lui
néandertal va se mettre à peindre des
grottes à partir de quarante mille ans
néandertal va aussi commencer à
fabriquer des colliers il ya entre à
partir de quarante mille ans néandertal
va aussi bas aussi comme je le disais
collecter des fossiles
intentionnellement on a ce magnifique
silex là avec le coquillage au milieu
qui a été gravé donc le silex a été
taillé le loup ti a été taillée autour
du coquillage fossiles dans l'intention
de préserver et de le mettre en valeur
donc ça c'est quand même un signe de
pensée abstraite
assez assez marquant et ça ça à 200
millions donc voilà il yal donc il ya
des signes de modernité culturelle qui
apparaissent au middle stone age avec
homo sapiens mais il faut pas perdre de
vue que en parallèle néandertal il est
aussi en train de faire sa source en
europe
et là c'est un peu trop tard pour que
pour que ça le sauve d'homo sapiens
toute façon je vois pas comment la
modernité culturelle aurait pu le sauver
mais bref c'est de toute façon c'est un
peu tard ces mêmes c'est même d'ailleurs
un peu tard pour que des gens ne fassent
pas l'hypothèse que m et didon est-ce
que c'est pas néandertal qui serait en
train de copier homo sapiens c'est une
hypothèse qui flotte à l'envers pourquoi
néandertal se met soudainement à la fin
de son règne entre guillemets à la fin
de son existence vers quarante mille ans
pourquoi néandertal se met soudainement
à peindre des grottes alors qu'on n'a
pas de signes de gros de tintin avant la
réponse n'est pas évidente par déjà à
partir de 80 mille ans 200 milles à 80
milles en homo sapiens hors d'afrique et
commence à coloniser le monde et apporte
sa culture avec lui donc il apporte le
middle stone age avec lui
ça se voit notamment dans le registre
fossile de chine est dans le registre
archéologique de chine et c'est pour ça
que les gens ont été très longtemps
farouchement opposés à une origine
d'homo sapiens en chine c'est parce que
en chine
ils passent littéralement de la culture
de moi erectus donc de lâcher les a
directement au middle stone age niveau
au niveau culture lithiques donc ça fait
un bond technologique qui indique
clairement que c'est quelqu'un d'autre
qui est arrivé et qui les a remplacés
quoi donc même si on ne trouve pas les
crânes en eux mêmes on trouve la culture
lithiques qui indique clairement qu'il
ya quelqu'un d'autre qui est arrivé
d'afrique avec son idole saône lg qui a
envahi le paysage culturel et
archéologique du coup de de l'extrême
orient
donc bref donc homo sapiens hors
d'afrique envahi le monde et on commence
à retrouver partout dans le monde des
produits culturels d'homo sapiens et ça
commence à exploser réellement à partir
de à partir de cinquante mille ans donc
à partir de 50 milles en bas on va
retrouver aussi loin que en en australie
on va commencer à retrouver
cinquante mille ans des grottes peinte
par exemple et puis ensuite en france
évidemment avec cosquer et et lascaux
est chauve est donc sauvé qui est la
plus vieille qui à 30,35 milan 35 37
mille ans l'asco qui a quinze mille ans
mais qui est aussi très jolie ou pas
faut pas la sous-estimer juste parce
qu'elle est plus jeune mais bref là là
on a vraiment des signes de modernité
culturelle très très prononcé avec même
ce qu'on commence éventuellement appelé
des civilisations c'est à dire qu'il ya
vraiment bas comme je le disais il ya la
modernité culture il ya la diversité
culturelle qui a commencé à apparaître
en afrique pendant le middle stone age
et à la sortie d'afrique d'homo sapiens
balles à fragmentation de ces cultures
s'intensifie et de fait on commence à
avoir des civilisations c'est à dire
qu'on peut commencer à identifier des
des populations unis par leur culture
leur culture du taillage d'outils mais
pas que
leur culture en général et cette
population unifié par des cultures se
peuvent se cartographier
géographiquement quoi donc à partir de
là on à homo sapiens dans sa forme la
plus homo sapiens possible et justement
la diapo précédente c'était pour
souligner que curieusement en afrique la
plus vieille grotte pintal a que 24
mille ans donc elle est beaucoup plus
jeune que la plus vieille grosse banque
d'australie ou d'europe
mais ça c'est un gros 2 1 c'est par ici
c'est vraiment un gros détail c'est ça
c'est quelque chose qui surprend
beaucoup les gens en fait c'est que
malgré toutes les recherches qui se font
en afrique sur les sur l'art pariétal
africain on n'a toujours pas retrouvé
d'art pariétal africain plus vieux que
24 milan alors pourtant qu'on a des
grottes magnifique beaucoup plus
ancienne que ça à deux autres bout du
monde donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne s'explique pas en quoi
mais évidemment la raison pour laquelle
je vous ai décrit tout ça c'est parce
que déjà rien que le fait de vous avoir
décrit la façon dont les cultures ont
évolué vous vous êtes rendu compte que
non seulement je focalisais sur la ligne
et qui menait à homo sapiens que je me
suis pas attardé sur les embranchements
de cette arborescence évolutive
quelle évolution humaine je me suis pas
attardé sur la culture d'homo erectus en
asie par exemple je n'ai pas réussi
j'ai complètement échoué à ne pas vous
parler de la culture de l'homme de
néandertal donc c'est un embranchement
dans cette évolution
mais voilà tout ça il y aurait fallu que
j'en parle si j'avais voulu vous
expliquer l'évolution de l'intelligence
humaine et je ne les ai pas fait parce
que c'est comme je dis c'est l'image
classique de l'évolution humaine de
prendre la ligne et qui mène à homo
sapiens et de parler que de ça et ça
c'est un billet que vous retrouvez dans
absolument tous les cours d'évolution
humaine dans absolument tous les livres
d'histoire enfin de d'archéologie et
paléontologie
c'est un billet qui est omniprésent dès
qu'on parle d'évolution du cerveau c'est
un graff avec le temps en abscisse non
le tendon est super mais je perds mes
mots
donc le temps la taille de cerveau et
hop
ont tracé une belle ligne qui montre que
la taille du cerveau augmente au fil du
temps et ça c'est donc le temps le temps
en abscisse la taille du cerveau en
ordonnée et zou voilà une belle ligne
une belle agression bien linéaire pour
vous montrer que la taille du cerveau
augmente avec le temps
c'est magnifique c'est magique mais
c'est autrement
beaucoup trop simple et puis on rajoute
par-dessus salle et les évolutions
technologiques s'est littéralement si
vous aussi vous gueulez évolution de
l'intelligence c'est exactement sur ce
graphe là que vous allez tomber
et là je suis je vous ai
intentionnellement présenter ce travers
là pour justement le contrastée avec une
vision un peu plus englobante de
l'évolution du cerveau et de
l'intelligence
d'ailleurs je dis ça mais même moi je le
fais là je vais vous expliquer là je
vais vous expliquer justement tous les
petits défauts qu'il ya là dedans
dans cette approche là mais moi même je
le fais quand je parle à mes premières
années de géologie
si vous allez voir la vidéo que je fais
de l'évolution humaine le travaux le tp
là les travaux pratiques que je donne
aux premières années de géologie je veux
bien c'est exactement ça que je leur dis
d'abord vous avez un petit cerveau puis
un cerveau moyens plus un gros cerveau
c'est exactement ça que je fais pas ce
que je veux dire on peut pas toujours
pas toujours plongé dans les détails dès
qu'on en a l'occasion c'est on a un
temps limité on a du temps de cerveau
limité avec nos étudiants ils sont pas
nos étudiants ils ont d'autres choses à
apprendre que les cours de
paléontologues tourangelle mais là ça
c'est un cours que je donne aux honors
donc eu par contre ils sont censés
pouvoir nuancer ce genre de choses et ça
et ça jeu et ça c'est important
justement de leur montrer d'abord ce
qu'il croit savoir et ensuite de passer
à la suite à savoir nuancer le propos
voilà et là j'ai choisi cette image là
parce que si vous gueulez human brain
évolution va vous tomber exactement sur
cette image là et cette image là elle
est très impressionnante parce qu'elle
elle a l'air hyper pro a c'est hyper pro
bass et l'image classique taille du
cerveau de ce côté là à l'horizontale
ici vous avez les dates dont qui sont
date log
rythmique apparemment pour que ça rentre
mais bref vous avez les dates ici
et puis vous avez le cerveau voilà chez
les australopithèques qui chez les
australopithèques signer dans lequel on
inclut les parents trope parce que après
tout pourquoi se priver et puis boum
ensuite les premiers représentants du
genre homo avec ici donc les homo
habilis et là les homo erectus et puis
boum les agace terre ici qui vont
conduire aux premiers homo-sapiens enfin
au premier représentant de d2 ce que
j'ai appelé tout à l'heure les late homo
donc les homos tardif à savoir et
d'albert gagnent 6 et néandertal et puis
ensuite vous avez homo sapiens l'eau
comme sapiens ici et puis évidemment
vous constatez qu on a tracé des jolis
traits qui montre bien quand même que la
taille du cerveau elles augmentent
1 évidemment on constate que la taille
du cerveau à l'augmenter et en parallèle
on vous met l'évolution culturelle alors
là c'est l'évolution culturelle c'est
une ligne une ligne complètement
arbitraire puisque on ne vous dit pas de
quelle façon elle a été quantifié
puisqu'il n'y a rien sur l' axe ya rien
sur l'axé vertical qui vous indiquent qu
est ce qui permet de quantifier cette
évolution culturelle
voilà donc donc ça c'est par une image
que j'ai pris au pif parce que justement
c'est une image qui a l'air très très
pros comme ça mais qui a énormément de
défauts et on va décortiquer justement
ces défauts ont déjà la première elle a
quand même des qualités cette image
c'est qu'elle vous montre la variabilité
donc on à la variabilité de la taille du
cerveau chez homo sapiens notamment la
qui est bien quantifier et qui est très
intéressant à regarder donc on peut voir
déjà qu'ils aient une variabilité que
cette variabilité et déjà elle permet à
première vue des dés le premier vivre
regarder le visuellement de constater
que oui alors on est d'accord que depuis
tout à l'heure on parle d'augmentation
de taille moyenne du cerveau parce que
si on se met à regarder effectivement
les les variabilités déjà sas nuance
ensuite l'évolution technologique donc
depuis tout à l'heure je vous dis
augmentation du quotient dans ses
valises à sion égale augmentation de
l'intelligence qu'on arrive à mettre en
parallèle avec augmentation
enfin technologie qui s'améliore et bien
déjà ce que ce qu'on peut constater sur
ce graphe c'est que en fait il ya des
couplages de l'évolution culturelle et
de l'évolution du cerveau en tout cas de
la taille du cerveau et je rappelle
qu'il n'ya que ça qu'on peut voir je me
rappelle donc et ce découplage il est
très très visible ici donc on à l'ohl
dubai a ici qui apparaît il ya 2,5
millions d'années alors qu'il n'existait
que des hominidés avec des cerveaux de
petite taille
voilà autour de 2,5 millions d'années il
n'y a pas encore d'hominidés avec un
dessert votre grande taille c'est
effectivement l'origine d'homo habilis
mais homo habilis à la base il n'a pas
un cerveau gigantesque et avant ça on
avait le le lot mais kwaï 1 qui
appareille à 3,3 millions d'années et
3,3 millions d'années yak des
australopithèques signer donc on a déjà
une transition depuis le lot mais khwaja
jusqu'à lol du vagin qui a lieu sans
aucun changement cérébrale notable voyez
transition de l'ohl du wild du lot mais
royal hall du voyage pas de changement
cérébrale ensuite on à l'apparition de
la schl est un lâche léa qui apparaît
donc ici donc là éventuellement on a
effectivement une augmentation de la
taille de cerveau qui a lieu avec
l'achever 1
et puis on a le début du du midol stone
age et là le début du middle stone age
voyaient en moyenne
il n'y a pas d'augmentation notable de
la taille du cerveau non plus pour le
pour le middle stone age et pareil pour
la domestication du feu à 600 mille ans
elle n'est pas particulièrement
accompagnée d'un changement particulier
dans la taille d'une moyenne du cerveau
donc vous avez deux énormes innovations
technologiques qui ont lieu sans
changement notable de la taille du
cerveau
et puis après vous avez une augmentation
notable de la taille du cerveau avec
l'apparition des homos tardif ou là on
va effectivement avoir le début du du
paléolithique supérieur notamment homo
sapiens justement et le début de ce
paléolithique supérieur et avec ce
paléolithique supérieur là par contre on
va avoir une augmentation
enfin ap
retire du paléolithique supérieur pardon
on va avoir une augmentation drastique
delà de la technologie sans changement
cérébrale notable voire même si on
regarde juste homo sapiens on vous
constaterez que les premières
populations d'homo sapiens avait un
servent une taille moyenne de cerveau
supérieur aux populations d'homo sapiens
moderne regarde l homo sapiens moderne
la taille moyenne elle va se trouver à
peu près là autour de 1300 centimètres
cubes entre 1300 et 1400 centimètres
cubes alors que ces homo sapiens la
halle les plus anciens ils ont ôté une
taille moyenne qui va plutôt se situer
par là autour de 1500 centimètres cubes
et ça c'est un phénomène qui est bien
connu il est tellement connu d'ailleurs
que vous voyez ils ont tracé une ligne
discrète certes mais quand même une
ligne en écrivant réduction de la taille
du cerveau d'homo sapiens voyez donc la
taille du cerveau d'homo sapiens elle
réduit alors même que la technologie
crève le plafond et ça c'est intéressant
comme phénomène
c'est intéressant comme phénomène mais
c'est le typiquement le genre de
phénomène que la plupart des graphes
vous vous cachez vous voyez il ya un
découplement entre le la technologie
enfin l'évolution des techniques et
l'évolution du cerveau non seulement ils
ne sont pas tout le temps corrélés un
changement technologique n'est pas
toujours accompagné d'un changement de
taille de cerveau mais en plus chez homo
sapiens notamment on a d'énormes
changements technologiques qui sont
accompagnés avec une diminution de la
taille du cerveau ça ça déjà rien que ça
ça vous sort des rails 1 ça vous sort
des rails ensuite ce genre de graff
généralement mais ça c'est une erreur
qu'on voit de moins en moins mais que je
vois toujours autant même dans les
publications scientifiques
ce genre de graff néglige totalement ou
presque à chaque fois presque
systématiquement l'existence de mona
lydie et d'homo floresiensis aumône à
l'e10 est homo floresiensis donc ce sont
des petits bonhommes que je vous
présente là ce sont deux hominidés qui
sont relativement récents dont common
allidina que 250 mille ans donc même pas
un quart de millions d'années et homo
floresiensis pareil il a entre 190 et 50
mille ans donc là c'est même pas un
dixième
même pas un dixième de millions d'années
pour le groupe donc vous avez un homo
qui a un quart de million d'années
l'autre qui a 10e 2 millions d'années
les deux ont été contemporain d'homo
sapiens et homo na li zhi a même vécu en
afrique en même tant qu'homo sapiens
donc les deux ont été contemporain
devant sapiens et pourtant sur le graphe
ils n'y sont pas et si on les placer sur
le graphe et bien il se trouverait là
très très loin de notre belle
augmentation de taille de cerveau et
donc en fait et ça ça vous change
complètement l'interprétation de ce
graphe qu'on voulait rajouter sur le
graphe vous passer d'une image général
d'augmentation moyenne de la taille du
cerveau à une image générale de
diversification de la taille du cerveau
le cerveau ne fait pas qu'augmenter en
taille non non il se diversifie en
taille vous avez des espèces qui
deviennent à gros cerveau et vous avez
des espèces qui restent à petit cerveau
est en réalité c'est même plus compliqué
que ça en réalité on va le voir sur les
diapos après c'est pas des espèces qui
reste un petit cerveau ce sont des
espèces dont le cerveau dans la taille
de cerveau se réduit en réalité mais on
va voir ça dans les diapos suivante
mais voyez là déjà on record ajoutant au
monal eddy homo floresiensis notre image
d'augmentation de la taille de cerveau
devient désormais une image de
diversification de la taille du cerveau
et ça c'est souvent quelque chose qui
est oublié dans l'est
ces représentations et enfin la dernière
chose à remarquer ici bas c'est que dans
le contexte d'une discussion de
l'évolution de l'intelligence parce que
l'a7 ce graphe là ce qui vous
représentent ils vous représente
l'évolution de la taille du cerveau en
fonction des techniques de l'évolution
technique
donc il essaie de vous vendre de
l'intelligence ce graphe pourtant il
utilise pas le quotient dans ses valises
à sion ah non à ccc des cds cubic
centimes et earth et des centimètres
cubes dont classe qui vous représentent
ces de la taille absolue de cerveau donc
qui ne tient pas compte du fait que les
crânes de ces bébêtes la rumba les
parents trope sont beaucoup plus petits
que les crânes d'homo sapiens moderne
est encore plus petit comparé à ceux des
homos rhodésienne si ce que vous voyez
là au morro deuxième si c'est même là
bas au mot longue il a le nous
le nouveau crâne qui a été découvert en
chine la harbin
c'est des monstres c'est des monstres
ces crânes sont beaucoup plus rock des
crânes humains modernes
sachant que les crânes humains modernes
sont déjà presque presque une fois et
demie plus gros que les crânes de
parents trope etc
donc on est donc là on ne s'affranchit
absolument pas du biez quelle est
l'augmentation de la taille corporelle
durant l'évolution humaine et de ce fait
et du fait qu'on ne considère pas le
quotient dans ses valises à sion en fait
on n'a aucune idée de si cette
augmentation de taille de cerveau peut
être raisonnablement interprété en
termes d'intelligence ce que je vous
rappelle que c'est ça tout l'intérêt du
quotient sensibilisation c'est de
pouvoir dire que la taille en plus de
cerveau qui est acquise peut être
raisonnablement interprétée comme étant
non fonctionnels donc comme étant de
l'intelligence enfin sachant que
l'intelligence et fonctionnel mais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire quoi donc
voilà donc vous voyez déjà avec tous les
défauts dont je vous parlais au début la
sur le quotient dans ses valises à sion
ça prend pas en compte les connexions ça
prend pas en compte le nombre de
neurones vous voyez même arriver là faut
encore faire la leçon sur pourquoi il
faudrait utiliser conscience et
validation plus que de juste la taille
brut de cerveau voyez que déjà rien que
le fait d'utiliser le cautionnement sefa
lisation vous êtes déjà un cran au
dessus comparé au contenu de base que
vous trouvez dans les livres de cours et
sur google sur internet sur les courses
sur internet et tout ça vous est déjà un
cran au dessus alors jade mer c'est pas
le maximum qu'on sait pas c'est pas
aussi bien que d'avoir accès à un
cerveau c'est sûr mais vous êtes déjà un
cran au dessus du niveau de base quoi
donc voilà donc ça c'est les choses
auxquelles il faut faire extrêmement
gaffe quand vous voyez ces choses et
c'est des choses que la plupart des des
étudiants ignorent donc et que je trouve
important de rappeler c'est que oui il
ya la technique la technologie qui
progresse mais cette technologie ne
progresse pas au même rythme que le
cerveau et l'évolution du cerveau telles
qu'on vous la raconte généralement nez
l'ifj totalement au mna lady homo
floresiensis et d'autres hominidés à
petit cerveau que j'ai pas rajouter
parce qu'il y en a d'autres des homo
erectus avec un tout petit cerveau il y
en a et généralement vont vous parle
même pas de caution dans ses valises à
sion donc en fait on vous parle même pas
l'intelligence
on vous parle juste vraiment de taille
de cerveau brut donc bon ça relativise
il ya beaucoup de niveaux à relativiser
à ce niveau-là et enfin la dernière la
dernière grosse remarque qu'il faut que
je fasse que je place c'est le fait que
la plupart de ces approches sur
l'évolution du cerveau ne sont pas
phylogénétique et ça c'est ça c'est
crucial
c'est absolument crucial ce que là vous
avez vous avez tous voilà comme je
disais vous avez l'accès des vous avez
lac se taillent de cerveau lax du temps
et une ligne et vous avez aucune prise
en compte de la phylogénie quelle
qu'elle soit dans cette danse dans ce
genre de graaf
vous n'avez aucune prise en compte de la
phylogénie et c'est pour ça que je
disais tout à l'heure que ça va être
important notamment dans
l'interprétation de est ce que le
cerveau diminue chez homo floresiensis
et au monal ai dit où est ce que le
cerveau reste de petites tailles chez
homo floresiensis et chez au monal ai
dit comment est ce qu'on va le savoir si
ce cerveau a diminué comment est-ce
qu'on va le savoir voilà si le ca si le
cerveau ici est devenu petit en partant
de là ou bien s'il est resté petit en
partant de là voilà en gros clairement
comment est-ce qu'on va le savoir si la
flèche aller dans cette direction là ou
bien si la flèche aller dans cette
direction si vers le bas eh ben il nous
faut une phylogénie il nous faut une
phylogénie et une fois que vous avez une
phylogénie balla vous pouvez commencer à
faire des affaires des hypothèses
évolutive sur l'évolution de la taille
du cerveau en l'absence de ses deux ça
n'avoir que le temps comme repère
évolutif c'est trop peu c'est trop peu
on peut faire mieux que ça et ça va être
notamment intéressant quand on parle
d'australopithecus parce que
l'australopithèque us n'est pas monofil
éthiques alors faut aller voir les cours
que j'ai fait sur la phylogénie pour ça
mais en gros pour pour faire simple
australopithèques us en fait c'est juste
une certaine quantité d'espèces qu'on
considère comme n'appartenant pas au
genre homo parce qu'elles sont trop
arboricole et
et ont un trop petit cerveau voilà donc
tout ce qu'il ya un petit cerveau et qui
arboricole ces australopithèques us vous
allez me dire mais c'est quoi la
différence avec le chimpanzé bah
justement
normalement on ne définit pas les
espèces à partir de très primitif là
vous avez typiquement australopithecus
c'est ce qui ressemble un petit peu au
genre homo mais pas suffisamment pour
être jambes
voilà et de ce fait aux australopithecus
vous avez des australopithecus donc
qu'ils sont très primitif tout à la base
de l'arbre et vous avez des
australopithecus qui sont très très
proches du genre homo comme par exemple
australopithecus sediba australopithecus
sediba qui pourrait même être considéré
comme un représentant du genre homo
selon certains critères donc donc voilà
est justement mettre tous à tout ce beau
monde là dans le même panier c'est à
dire des trucs qui ont 4 millions
d'années qui sont hyper primitif comme
australopithecus ramidus et des trucs de
seulement 2 millions d'années donc deux
millions d'années plus jeunes comme
australopithecus sediba et qui ressemble
à morat au mot et qui en sont
probablement phylogénétiquement proches
les mettre tous dans le même panier
ça vous donne une image hyper simplifiée
de l'évolution humaine
vous mettez tout ça dans le même panier
évidemment vous allez dire que homo a
forcément un plus gros cerveau
d'australopithecus puisque vous avez
défini australopithecus comme étant un
plus petit cerveau bah oui mais il faut
pas regarder que ça va pas regarder que
ça et c'est sale avantages de la proche
phylogénétique c'est qu'on ne regarde
pas qu'un seul caractère pour faire
notre classification ou 10 caractères ou
20 caractères on en regarde des dizaines
voire même des centaines et on les
ordonne de façon d'une façon statistique
c'est à dire d'une façon répétable
surtout c'est à dire qu'on donne pas
plus de valeur à caractère parce que moi
j'ai décidé que ce caractère là avec
plus de valeur non non c'est l'analyse
cladistique l' analyse phylogénétique ça
c'est pas une alice claudie stx et une
analyse bayésienne mais bref c'est l'
analyse phylogénétique qui va en donner
les caractères pour vous et qui va
donner de l'importance aux caractères si
vous dites à l'analyse de donner de
l'importance en caractère autrement on
donne même pas d'importance plus
d'importance à certains caractères qu'à
d'autres normalement tous les caractères
ont la même importance
mais voilà mais voilà la proche
phylogénétique elle est hyper importante
vous avez pas rentrer au plus par
exemple qui est
espèce à petit cerveau qui a évolué en
parallèle du genre homo
donc c'est vous aviez le genre homo qui
commençait à avoir un gros cerveau et en
parallèle vous n'avez pas rentrer opus
qui lui est resté un petit salon en
parallèle voyez quelque chose qui se
voit pas là sur le graphe ça s'est passé
en parallèle et comme je disais vous
avez australopithecus sediba qui est
très très proche du genre homo mais qui
a toujours un petit cerveau et en se
privant d'une analyse phylogénétique
dans se prive de cette information-là
information qui est on peut être proche
du genre homo et avoir un petit sabre
information qui devient crucial quand on
se met à intégrer des espèces justement
comme homos na li est homo floresiensis
deux espèces du genre homo à petit
cerveau voilà et ça c'est juste une
phylogénie c'est la phylogénie dont j'ai
parlé dans le dernier paléo news c'est
juste pour la remettre parce qu'elle est
génial c'est juste pour la remettre pour
la donner aux étudiants pour que les
étudiants sachent qu'il y a une fille
laugénie du genre homo de tous les homos
du pléistocène et que c'est beau c'est
beau voilà mais je digresse et donc
qu'est ce qui se passe quand on se met à
regarder l'évolution de quotient dans
ses valises à sion sur une phylogénie
des hominidés bas ça donne ça un article
qui a été écrit entre autres par ornella
bertrand donc paléontologues française
spécialiste encore une paléo
neurologiste donc cet article d'ornellas
bertrand et bien il nous il nous dit que
le quotient dans ses valises à sion donc
la corriger pour la phylogénie c'est
pour ça qu'il a happé devant le cul ce
quotient la sefa lisation et donc il
était petit à la base un normal donc là
on me dit aux alentours de 20.6 donc ils
ont utilisé une autre façon de calculer
location dans ses valises à sion dans
laquelle du coup les plus les espèces à
plus gros cerveau n'ont qu'un quotient
dans ses valises à sion 2 3 mais ne
soyez pas perturbé par cette petite
valeur c'est juste qu'elle a utilisé une
façon différente de calculer le quotient
dans ses valises à sion mais l'important
c'est de regarder les valeurs comparer
les unes aux autres et donc on commence
avec un petit coefficient dans ses
valises à sion puis quand on atteint les
australopithèques par affinity
le coefficient sefa lisa sion on monte
un peu il devient violet est donc ce qui
est intéressant c'est de regarder ce qui
se passe dans le genre homo donc le
genre homo commence en violet et quand
vous allez voir les branches d'homo
floresiensis et de au monal ai dit
qu'est ce qui se passe on est sur des
branches qui sont quasiment jaune orange
et qui repasse dans le violet est pareil
pour au monal ai dit vous avez une
branche qui démarre jaune orange et qui
repasse dans le viol est la taille du
cerveau qui se réduit le cerveau a
augmenté chez leurs ancêtres de taille
et chez home et dans la branche qui a
mené au modèle est dit et en parallèle
dans la branche qui va mener un homo
floresiensis cette taille de cerveau en
face cette caution dans ses valises à
sion a diminué donc c'est pas seulement
la réduction de la taille du corps chez
homo floresiensis qui a entraîné la
taille du cerveau là on a une diminution
du quotient dans ses valises à sion donc
comme il ya une réduction de la taille
du cerveau et du corps ça se voit moins
fort que chez homo naledi on est
d'accord mais c'est pas le nanisme
insulaires qui fait que homo
floresiensis à un petit cerveau ça ne
s'explique pas que par la taille du
corps c'est le l'encéphale isation c'est
à dire le poids de la taille du cerveau
sur la taille du cerveau attendu est
aussi plus petit chez homo floresiensis
la réduction de l'encéphale isation est
un phénomène qui existe dans le genre
homo et ça ça ne se ça il faut pas le
prendre à la légère
faut pas prendre à la légère la ce que
j'aime vous sortir la réduction de la
taille
la réduction de l'encéphale isation est
un phénomène réel dans l'évolution
humaine
quand on vous a appris toute votre vie
que le cerveau la taille du cerveau
elles augmentent chez l'humain c'est pas
vrai voilà c'est pas vrai il ya des fois
où la taille du cerveau diminue plus
d'une fois
une fois chez homo naledi une fois chez
florensis et même une fois chez sapiens
je voulais dit tout à l'heure
donc ça existe des réductions de taille
du cerveau et de fête
rappelez-vous de fait dire que
australopithèques us
c'est comme homos mais avec un petit
cerveau en gros c'est tout ce qui a un
petit cerveau c'est forcément
australopithecus ça peut rien être
d'autre
eh bien c'est faux et c'est pour ça
qu'on se retrouve avec des sediba au
milieu des homos du coup c'est pour ça
qu'on se retrouve avec australopithecus
sediba groupe frère de homo habilis
c'est parce qu'on n'a australopithecus
sediba qui a été placée dans le genre
australopithèques pourquoi ma passe sur
la base de caractère primitif
la petite taille du cerveau et le lard
borie colis et si au mot et est capable
d'être arboricole et si au monde et est
capable d'avoir un petit cerveau et
sachant que d'avoir un petit cerveau
c'est quelque chose qui s'acquiert c'est
pas forcément un caractère primitif
c'est pas forcément une rétention d'un
caractère primitif avoir un petit
cerveau peut évoluer un petit cerveau
même quand on appartient à la lignée
homo est là là c'est pareil là ça prend
faut prendre le temps de s'asseoir et
d'en mesurer les conséquences sur tout
ce que vous croyez savoir ce révolution
humaine faut prendre le temps de
s'asseoir et d'en mesurer les
conséquences
je vous laisse faire ça et on en est à
peu près sûr aussi de ça c'est parce que
en fait quand on regarde l'évolution de
certains sur six qui sont visibles sur
le moulage endocriniens donc il y en a
pas beaucoup qui sont visibles sur le
moulage en craignant je vous le dis mais
il ya notamment le sucre cus qui
délimite le cortex frontal ce circus se
succèdent vous voyez il est divisé en 2
chez les
les genres au moderne incluant fâché le
genre homo incluant homo sapiens moderne
mais par contre il est en est simple
chez australopithecus est en fait les
premiers représentants du genre homo
donc homo habilis typiquement avait
insulté us qui est simple comme
australopithèques us et du coup si une
espèce avait un cerveau primitif
à la base on s'attend donc à ce qu'elle
ait un succube simple et non pas un seul
cus divisée en deux et bien au monal
eddy est homo floresiensis on insulte us
divisé en deux dans leur cortex frontal
ils ont un style plus divisée en deux ce
qui veut bien dire qu'ils avaient un
cerveau évoluer avant de retrouver un
cerveau simple à savoir petit cerveau
voilà et ça c'est beau c'est beau ce
genre de choses c'est beau de voir ce
genre de choses c'est beau donc
maintenant la question pour terminer
j'ai envie de dire la question de la
viande donc du régime carné sur
l'évolution humaine qui est une question
qui revient sans cesse d'une question
qui est central à l'évolution humaine
vraiment est ce que c'est le régime
carné de homo qui lui a permis de
d'avoir un cerveau plus gros déjà il
faut mettre ça en évidence qu'il ya un
régime carné plus franche et aux mots
que chez les autres espèces donc pour ça
on a fait des analyses isotopiques alors
on savait déjà sur la base morphologie
sur des bases anatomique et sur la base
des outils aussi on savait déjà que le
genre homo et est mieux adapté à la
nourriture carnet que ses congénères par
entrup et australopithèques us mais ça a
été confirmée par des analyses
isotopiques qui ont montré du coup vous
voyez là le australopithecus donc qui
est un généraliste je veux dire qu'ils
mangent de tout est ici vous avez pas
rentrer up qui a des isotopes du carbone
qui sont très différents en fait une
signature isotopique du carbone qui est
très différente de celle de homo alors
là les isotopes c'est la géochimie c'est
la chimie osseuse en l'occurrence ici la
chimie de l'émail plus qu'ils ont fait
ça sur les dents et donc la chimie
my reflète le régime alimentaire surtout
quand on regarde le carbone et donc ça
veut dire que par entre up est homo
avait un régime alimentaire très
différent très différents et part en
europe au niveau de son anatomie
il est à l'évidence herbivores veut dire
il a une crête sagittale gigantesque
comme les gorilles des normes des normes
marcaggi galles pour les muscles master
qui donne à la mâchoire une énorme
puissance mastic à trice et une énorme
puissance mastic à trice c'est pas pour
manger de la viande c'est pour manger
des de la végétation parce que les
fibres végétales sont beaucoup plus dur
que les fibres que que la fibre les
protéines qu'on retrouve dans la viande
et les dents sont absolument gigantesque
hyper épaisse on parle de mes gars dont
6 et elles sont extrêmement usées quand
on retrouve les parents trope on
retrouve les dents qui sont complètement
aplati hyper usées pourquoi parce que la
fibre végétale encore une fois est
beaucoup plus corrosive que les fibres
que les fibres animales que les fibres
musculaires animal donc l'analyse
isotopique en fait confirme que homo
avait un régime alimentaire très
différent de celui de parent trope et
donc que homo avait un régime
alimentaire
opposé à celui de parent trap quoi donc
à savoir plus carnivore que pas rentrer
ça veut pas dire qu'on est capable de
dire exactement quelle quantité de
viande y manger et si c'est très
probable qu'ils étaient omnivore
attendant ce carnivore là ou pas rentrer
up était vraiment spécialiste herbivore
parce que ça reste quand même en ligne
vous voyez avec le régime alimentaire
des australopithèques enfin la signature
isotopique des australopithèques donc on
reste quand même sur de l'omni vori mais
à tendance plus carnivore que les
parents trope et ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle la partition des niches
écologiques c'est à dire que parent trap
et homos ont pu coexister justement
parce qu'ils ne mangeaient pas la même
chose maintenant qu'on a mis en évidence
qu'il y avait effectivement un
changement du régime alimentaire chez
homo peu vers un régime plus carnet est
ce que ça ç'a eu de l'affluence sur le
cerveau alors il ya deux grandes
hypothèses qui traînent dans la
littérature scientifique et ses deux
grandes hypothèses disent que oui
oui ça a eu de l'influencé parce que la
première c'est que c'est parce que en
fait la viande est plus riche enrichit
le régime alimentaire du moins quand on
est omnivore et qu'on a en plus de la
viande ça enrichit le régime alimentaire
et du coup ça donne plus d'énergie au
cerveau et sa ceux qui connaissent la
chaîne savent que je suis pas
spécialement d'accord avec cet argument
tout simplement parce que le cerveau n'a
pas besoin de protéines
il a besoin de sucre le cerveau a besoin
de sucre pour fonctionner pas de
protéines donc je suis pas spécialement
d'accord avec ça il ya une autre
hypothèse par contre qui dit que manger
de la viande ça requiert un plus petit
intestin
pourquoi parce que la viande la viande
c'est effectivement plus riches dans
beaucoup d'autres nutriments pas le
sucre mais c'est effectivement plus
riches en plein d'autres nutriments
du coup on n'a pas besoin d'un aussi
grand intestin que pour digérer les
fibres végétales qui elles sont
extrêmement coriace et très peu riche en
nutriments encore que ça dépend des
végétaux vous mangez je suis d'accord
mais dans la savane africaine dans la
savane africaine c'est pas très riche et
comme c'est ce contexte là qui nous
intéresse les plantes sont pas hyper
riches dans la savane africaine donc on
a kiffé ctive mans le fait d'avoir
ajouté de la viande au régime
alimentaire a permis une réduction du
système digestif
ça oblige aussi une réduction du système
digestif parce que la viande a tendance
à moisir dans le système digestif et du
coup ça c'est pas cool d'avoir de la
viande moisi dans le tube digestif
ça peut provoquer des problèmes des
problèmes assez évident d'affection
notamment dont bref donc ce système
digestif plus court en fait basse et de
l'énergie économisée pour pouvoir faire
d'autres organes
en gros donc on économise des protéines
de construction des blocs de base pour
pouvoir construire d'autres organes et
notamment le cerveau on parle pas
d'ailleurs ne dit pas que le cerveau a
augmenté de taille pour la chasse parce
qu'on suppose c'est ce que cette image
rappel on suppose que les premiers
the minis des était plutôt dès les
premiers représentants du genre homo
pour être clair les premiers
représentants du genre homo on propose
qu'ils étaient des charognards
donc on pense pas que l'intelligence a
augmenté pour la chasse c'est
probablement faut donc il était
probablement charognards ont enrichi
leur régime alimentaire de viande et
c'est ensuite qu'ils ont développé la
chasse pour enrichir de leur régime
alimentaire de plus de viande et donc ça
le fait d'avoir un intestin plus réduit
ça libère des briques pour pouvoir
construire d'autres organes et notamment
le cerveau et ça à la limite je pourrais
être d'accord si on n'avait pas un
contre exemple assez magistrale qui est
les éléphants à gros cerveau parce que
je vous ai dit les éléphants aujourd'hui
les éléphants moderne
ils sont relativement intelligents
certes mais ils ne sont ils n'ont pas un
cerveau qui est plus gros que le cerveau
qu'on attend d'un animal de 5 tonnes
voilà donc un cerveau de 4,5 kg c'est ce
qu'on attend d'un animal de 4,5 tonnes
en fait donc leur cerveau est pas
spécialement plus gros que ce con que la
normale entre guillemets si on peut
appeler ça si on peut appeler caution
dans ses valises à sion égal à la
normale alors les éléphants n'ont pas un
cerveau beaucoup plus gros que la
normale il ya certains éléphants qui ont
un cerveau deux fois plus gros que la
normale mais ils n'iront pas plus loin
ils iront pas jusqu'à 7
sauf sauf l'éléphant d'un de sicile
l'éléphant d'un de sicile qui vous est
représentée ici vous voyez la taille du
crâne et vous voyez la taille du cerveau
comparé à la taille du crâne et la
taille du cerveau d'un éléphant
classique donc l'éléphant n'aime sicile
lui par contre il a un cerveau
gigantesque et un cautionnement sefa
lisation que j'ai pu calculer moi-même
qui s'estiment de l'ordre de 4 voire 5
voire même jusqu'à 7
mais en général la plupart des auteurs
s'accordent pour dire quatre à cinq
donc on a un quotient dans ses valises à
sion qui est équivalent au genre homo
voire même aux représentants tardif du
genre homo et tout ça avec un régime
alimentaire herbivores à dire les
éléphants les éléphants d'anne cécile
tout le reste de leur anatomie est 100%
éléphantine c'est juste qu'ils sont tout
petits et ils ont un cerveau
et non donc on peut avoir un quotient
dans ses valises à sion très élevé donc
un gros cerveau donc dédié beaucoup
d'énergie et de briques à la
construction d'un cerveau
proportionnellement très gros par
rapport au poids de votre corps le tout
en étant herbivores et là on est
herbivore avec les éléphants d'annecy
s'il en est sûr de l'air bizarre street
c'est à dire de l'herbivore qui mangent
de l'herbe même pas de l'herbivore qui
mangent des fruits ou des feuilles des
trucs qui sont un peu plus nourrissant
en herbe
le truc le moineau et 100 de la planète
donc donc ce ce contre exemple la
m'incite à penser que quand même cette
deuxième cette deuxième hypothèse bien
calé un peu plus séduisante que la
première soit je dois l'avouer ça reste
moyen et que mon avis on néglige quelque
chose dans ces hypothèses en disant que
la viande a été un instrument clé de
l'évolution du cerveau chez dans le
genre homo on néglige quelque chose et
ce quelque chose il a probablement à
voir avec la liste colossal de d'autres
facteurs qui ont une corrélation
positive avec la taille du cerveau parce
que l'intelligence c'est peut-être une
chose à la quand on regarde dans les
grandes lignes de l'évolution des
mammifères
on voit qu'effectivement les animaux les
plus intelligents sont ceux qui ont plus
gros cerveau donc les dauphins ici vous
avez les humains ici et vous avez les
éléphants ici alors on est bien d'accord
ceux qui ont le plus gros cerveau sont
généralement et puis on a même les
chevaux l'âge on a parlé de tout à
l'heure les animaux les plus enfin les
mammifères les plus intelligents sont
généralement ceux qui ont plus gros
cerveau on est d'accord mais par contre
faut pas non plus laisser de côté la
quantité colossale d'autres on appelle
ça des traits d'histoires de vie
d'autres facteurs biologiques qui sont
aussi attachés à une augmentation de la
taille du cerveau et parmi eux on a le
taux métabolique donc un savoir la
température de votre corps pour dire les
choses simplement
la température de votre corps se est
liée à la taille de votre cerveau et
chez les dauphins notamment saint jouer
un rôle probablement essentiel dans leur
survie les
adapté aux milieux aquatiques ça
nécessite de générer énormément de
chaleur pour pas pourquoi mourir
d'hypothermie et leur gros cerveau a
peut-être évoluer en réponse à ça donc
ils ont peut-être un gros cerveau avant
tout pour générer de l'énergie pour
générer de de l'énergie générée du sang
chaud voilà et donc le fonctionnement de
leur cerveau génère du sang chaud mais
ça génère aussi en parallèle de
l'intelligence du coup donc
l'intelligence se serait qu'un effet
secondaire de l'évolution du cerveau on
a aussi la longueur de la vie les
animaux qui ont la durée de vie la plus
longs sont aussi les animaux qui ont le
plus gros cerveau les animaux qui ont le
temps de gestation les plus longs sont
aussi les animaux qui ont plus gros
cerveau les animaux qui ont le plus de
soins parentaux ou s'il plus gros
cerveau les animaux qui ont généralement
un gros corps ont plu au cerveau il n'y
a pas vraiment de petits mammifères qui
ont un gros cerveau vous pouvez le voir
ici les quotients l'encéphale isation
les plus élevés se retrouvent chez les
animaux qui ont qui font partie de ce
qu'on appelle la mégafaune donc les
animaux qui ont un grand cautionnant ses
valises à sion aussi quand même font
plutôt partie des animaux de grande
taille vous avez les animaux qui ont à
des détails de groupes relativement
élevé donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le
social brain les potez du cerveau social
ou en fait le cerveau le gros cerveau
sert avant tout à gérer les relations
sociales et notamment plus le groupe est
grand et plus vous avez de relations
sociales à gérer et pareil le cerveau
augmente de taille et ensuite génère de
l'intelligence presque par effets
secondaires maintenant si le cerveau
humain avait essentiellement évolué hier
en corrélation pour enfin après c'est
des hypothèses qui n'ont pas été encore
retrouvé avec la littérature mais je
trouve que c'est suffisamment riche en
question pour qu'on puisse les
mentionner ces questions c'est on sait
que l'être humain a à a
une régulation de son métabolisme assez
spécial on est parmi les seuls
mammifères qui succombent parce qu'on a
plus de poils on est les seuls
mammifères qui succombent pour réguler
notre température corporelle
donc on a un on a un métabolisme qui est
différent de celui des autres mammifères
est ce qu'il aurait pas un lien avec
l'intérêt de notre cerveau est ce que la
façon dont on régule notre métabolisme
qui est si particulière n'aurait pas un
lien aussi avec l'évolution de notre
cerveau ici le fait d'avoir un gros
cerveau n'était qu'un effet secondaire
d'autres choses enfin et c'est la grande
question que je veux vous poser avec
cette diapos qui est la diapo final
c'est enfin c'est pas la question que je
veux vous poser c'est plus la remarque
finale vraiment là l'idée que je veux
vous ramener à la maison
voilà dans votre lit ce soir en allant
vous coucher c'est et si dans
l'évolution du cerveau l'intelligence
n'était pas le facteur de sélection
naturelle principal est ce que quand on
constate une augmentation de la taille
du cerveau une augmentation de
l'encéphale isation dans une lignée
particulières comme les homininés est ce
qu'on est vraiment en train de regarder
un effet de la sélection naturelle sur
l'intelligence ou bien est-ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de constater un effet
de la sélection naturelle sur le taux
métabolique
par exemple je reprends l'exemple des
dauphins mais les dauphins sont très
connus pour leur intelligence ils sont
très connus pour leurs gros cerveau je
ne le nie pas mais est ce que
l'intelligence est né du gros cerveau ou
est ce que l'intelligence à stimuler le
gros cerveau est ce que les sélection
naturelle agissez vraiment sur
l'intelligence
quand le cerveau des dauphins augmenté
en taille ou bien est-ce que la
sélection naturelle n'étaient pas en
train d'agir sur la thermorégulation en
train de dire aux cerveaux jeu
personnifie la sélection naturelle c'est
une horreur de finaliste mais vous
comprenez l'idée est ce que la sélection
naturelle n'étaient pas en train de dire
au cerveau augmente de taille génère de
la chaleur génère de la chaleur génère
de là
général de la chaleur le cerveau et
grossit grossit grossit grossit sauf que
l'effet secondaire le deuxième effet
kiss cool bas c'est qu'avec un gros
cerveau vous produisez de l'intelligence
et pouf les dauphins devient en plus de
mieux réguler la température de leur
corps en plus les dauphins deviennent
intelligents ça je me permets de le dire
parce que ça a été publié comme
hypothèse ans c'est publié depuis 2006
il ya un neurologiste qui s'appelle paul
vendeurs qui est vraiment le leader dans
cette idée là mais qui rallie de plus en
plus de monde et qui publie de plus en
plus de gros papier là dessus c'est une
théorie qui existe en vrai pour les
dauphins et d'ici à ce qu'on se rende
compte que c'est peut-être pareil pour
les humains est ce que la taille du
cerveau seraient pas liés aussi avant
tout à la façon si spécial qu'ont les
humains de réguler leur température du
corps
eh bien eh ben je serais pas surpris de
voir ça dans la littérature à paraître
bientôt
ça y est pas encore en tout cas pas que
je sache dans la littérature peut-être
que vous connaissez un papier dans ce
cas là je suis très intéressé le voir
que je sache ce n'est pas encore dans la
littérature mais je ne serais pas
surpris de le voir pop et un jour dans
la littérature ce qui dès la queue et si
l'intelligence n'était pas la cible
principale de la sélection naturelle
dans les lignées ou un gros cerveau
évolué et si l'intelligence n'était que
le second effet kiss cool
le petit le petit effet secondaire
puisque c'est le mot à la mode en ce
moment
le petit effet secondaire auxquels on
s'attendait pas et qui a bomb a
maintenant que tu es là installe toi
maintenant que tu es là installe toi et
puis rends-toi utile c'est quelque chose
d'intelligent à voilà donc je vous
laisse avec cette idée là à très bientôt
à la semaine prochaine donc pour un
prochain cours nous parlerons cette fois
de l'évolution des cétacés mes petits
chouchous salut